[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
of the careful boys we got
ryan in the hot seat yeah how's it going
the exceptionally sterile lukewarm seat
until it gets fired up a little bit
later
sterile oh god thank you a very specific
time that's all right we don't know
anything about you but the people who
don't know who the [ __ ] ryan is you know
ryan's been with us for what over
seven years now it's like six six years
six years yeah damn it he's been he's
been around you know but uh you know
mainly mostly behind the scenes mostly
yeah on camera tekken do all that you
know editing or when like a guest
doesn't show up yeah or yeah or with
last minute fill-in
which people like by the way they like
they like that you represent the
thoughts of the audience actually you
know the common man
the street man the every man the simple
the asian you bring the asian flair in
here yeah definitely definitely didn't
have enough of that japanese food all
right japanese food japanese american
flair which is uh
the
sixth generation like like yeah third or
fourth thing yeah close enough
it's been here since the 1400s let's say
eighth generation japanese man my family
came here on asteroids
[Laughter]
all right so uh you can't win the
[ __ ] dinosaur meteor guy you did like
edits and stuff right yeah yeah
so just [ __ ] worst guess that you had
to edit
we need to start with something cooler
yeah what's your least favorite race
yeah the japanese
the same answer right yeah [ __ ] those
guys they're all like neat and orderly
and organized and
stay in their homes for too long
what's your favorite color socks
favorite color socks this was so cold
it's so good
he's killing the game dude honestly it's
really impressive yeah i'm like
black socks because they don't yeah they
don't do they don't show like the
nastiness after a while
exactly that's pretty cool just do no
socks bro that's the coolest kind of
socks invisible socks how many how many
guns do you have
three now i just bought a new one wow
you're very conservative yeah well it's
also because i don't have a lot of money
so there's that too
i know a lot of people that don't have a
lot of money and they still buy guns i'd
like to think that i'm fiscally
responsible if money was no object what
gun or weapon would you get if i wasn't
in california there'd be so many [ __ ]
guns i'd get because i live in
california don't be too angry while
we're talking about this california
house texas laws and you have infinite
gun money funds yeah yeah what are the
the first five ten guns you buy [ __ ]
five five ten
five ten what's the first small country
you wanna overthrow
[Laughter]
not that much people own like 30 guns
and stuff they do yeah easily uh i think
i'd probably start with an sti like a
dvc like that's a good one
yeah or there's staccato now but yeah
staccato yeah 2011 something something
racist
what does that look like i'm a
connoisseur but there's a lot of gun
idiots here that don't know about this
stuff you could just like you know yeah
share something i know everything i'm
i'm a man
you're a man's man it's a handgun
a 50 cal cowabunga it's like a car it's
like a five thousand dollar pistol
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] sick typically
used for
competition where they like shoot
targets and they run john wick one you
know he has one uh his the last latest
movie they do have one yeah especially
this sweet
go fast eat ass what is that a nine mil
yeah it's a nine mil yeah i'd probably
get it in nine two cause it's like the
only caliber that i really wanna own um
other than that i think a really nice
over under shotgun so like for like
traffic nellie m4r no no like uh like a
beretta like an italian shotgun like
that's what i want because like those
things are classy like twenty thousand
dollar shotgun yeah yeah yeah something
like that that's like hand filigreeds
they got like carved like so those are
the ones you guys see duck hunters
a musket like a black powder musket
the longer it takes for you to shoot it
the classier of shooting it is because
it's like it's kind of like golf like
you really got to want to like spend an
entire [ __ ] day like doing whatever
you want it's not about the murder it's
about the craft yeah it's about the
craft getting to the eventual murder
yeah but you can be classy about it yeah
it's not like fast food it's f it's like
fine dining but guns oh that's good
analogy then i'd buy a bunch of meme
guns that are just like [ __ ] garbage
what's a meme like dodge gun
gun like [ __ ] like that like there's
a gun called a high point that's like
200 bucks
yeah i'd buy one of those and then i'd
like have like some custom shop like
race it out just for fun get a prank gun
that like shoots the shooter just look
right here
when i give it to my friend and i'm like
hey this one's really fun
after it shoots the start
enthusiasm thing like immediately after
she was like
a little bit warmer now you've been
working with jk yeah for six years yeah
what is your least favorite jk project
so far least favorite jk princess like
jk news
jk music
i hate careful boys and danger boys
probably jk party being completely
honest yeah it's just jk party was a
very draining show to work on for me
because it was just a lot of
cleanup before and after a lot of the
times so a lot of the stuff was like and
it was always all over the place like it
was it was standardized to a certain
extent but it was like it was like a
full day of shooting and it was
we had a lot of games that i got used to
like i'm super [ __ ] tired of them off
you know like i'm just super bored but
they love it dude
they still want more like half of the
the mafias that have been played now and
i'm just like i've seen everything
basically so it'd be a combination of
stuff that's really [ __ ] boring
started playing yeah we just started
dude oh yeah so i'm tired of mafia too
i'm with you but then you do like five
years of it and then you're just like
damn this [ __ ] i hope the fans keep on
[ __ ] asking for mafia knowing that we
all hate it i feel like you guys too
understand our gameplay yeah and it's so
hard to like come out of left field and
then you can kind of see how it's going
to unfold because he's got like the
weakest gameplay in party the weakest
gameplay yeah
i mean what that's still like playing
yes from the editor's point of view oh i
mean i don't i don't edit party anymore
yeah but it's pr it's probably between
like now the people that are playing it
probably like michael or me one of the
two because my michael just gets way too
sweaty but he kind of leans into it so
he's
sometimes i'm like looking at him like
it's modern like damn do you look guilty
as [ __ ]
he's like
everyone go to sleep
exactly i'm just like wait did i do that
right there's been a couple of times
where i'm like moderating the game i'm
like [ __ ] did i [ __ ] this up did i why
are you so [ __ ] guilty yeah i don't
know man that's just michael but yeah
what's the one thing that like like joe
or bart pissed you off the most in your
life
what do you hate the most about this
even if it's like a single incident like
they just said something just happened
they were just being a dick about
something just i think you could just
tell us you don't have to say it yeah
yeah
huddle up guys just we'll just turn this
way and there's no way that they can
hear it no i think that there's been a
couple times on party where we spend a
lot of time building something or like
building the rules to something and then
just towards them taking it like eat it
off of this off of the table i was just
like
or like or like or like when joe would
like yak on things or like yeah like yak
on things it'd be like ah bro i gotta
clean that later dude oh [ __ ] me i try
my best to clean it myself
i try to eat my own throw up one time
too yeah you act on stuff you act on the
ground the grass is the hardest thing to
clean [ __ ]
there's been a lot of like spicy
challenges oh from the stuff you guys
eat
on a content perspective it's like that
was them upping the ante so i like kind
of got it i was like this would keep me
watching the video but it's
different when you're watching it
knowing that you need to clean it up
afterwards it's like there's a cleaning
aspect there's times where they have to
pull like
almost pretty much like move out half of
the stuff from our other studio and
spray it down with the hose the tarp the
tarp was supposed to make our lives
easier but it almost made it harder
because we would need to like lay out
this big ass [ __ ] black tarp to like
i'll have all the liquids and stuff
spill on it and then we pick it up move
it to the outside and then hose it off
but then we can't just leave it there so
we did then like wipe it off and it was
just it was just a whole process to do
so stuff like that um when we were those
two guys man you guys props did you ever
have you ever felt like do i want to
[ __ ] quit
you know there's some of those moments
where i was just like do i need to do
this
but
i get so much more respect on my other
dog you know what's crazy about jk party
though
is we love the fans so much
it was even at the point where
i think we were all tired of it really
not anyone we're not even making money
from it like we had jk
pay for jk party yeah but all of us got
together because also too at the time
to make sure that you guys had a like
you guys as in the team
had a full-time enough job where you
didn't have to take up other gigs and
stress about money it made sense to keep
jk news because it did make enough money
to where like we could share like both
things keep everyone busy and then like
everyone has money to live right so then
it was one of those things where like
okay it was good enough but even if at
that moment if we were more like
business savvy we would have just got
rid of it and created a new concept but
then also the fans loved it so it was
like
they we hated mafia by ear too but
they're like keep doing more so we're
like all right [ __ ] it listen some
people re-watch
one mafia episode they just really like
that one and they'll just keep watching
it over and over and over but then it
got to the point where it was just like
yo let's just do this for the passion of
it
and then that's when i was like it's
kind of cool that everyone assembled
together
and kind of made these sacrifices to
just make it work and we probably went
like two plus years more than it should
have yeah oh yeah definitely right
hundred percent
100 we're still doing it so is it like
three plus years or more
well this is it's overheads a lot less
yes it's cheaper we can afford it and
it's on patreon and then so it's without
the pressure of having such a big office
and channel we can just genuinely have
fun like friends in the living room like
before there was a full-on writing team
writing the concepts out and then
there's a producing team like if we were
doing the what's in the box i'm gonna
have to go buy a lobster or go buy some
red i did some of that yeah yeah i was
way too crazy before now it's just
really stupid games yeah now we have a
genius ryan playing songs that we just
guessed what they are yeah
today's video is brought to you by
tis the season of gift giving but you
shouldn't forget about yourself why not
give yourself the gift of financial
freedom with upstart upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off your personal
debt with a loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards or consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over 1 million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a payoff date rather than looking
at your credit score alone upstart
considers other factors like your income
current employment and credit history to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between 1 000 to 50 000
you can even receive funds as fast as
one business day after being accepted
for your loan find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payment today by
going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart u p s t a
r t dot com slash o f f t h e r e c o r
d don't forget to use the url so they
know that we sent you guys loan amounts
will be determined by your credit income
and other information provided on your
loan application go to upstart.com off
the record and people still love it but
it's not the same for production's much
lower like in the sense where like the
talent sucks now yeah way especially
when you're on
before like swimming in milk and like i
don't know just crazy [ __ ] trying to
melt ice cubes it's [ __ ] nuts yeah
well speaking of ryan's hot seat um yeah
of all the guests that have come out
here which one did you want to like
smash the most
don't want to smash them yeah female
guess hopefully people are male's fine
you're talking about the hips yeah like
[ __ ] like attract the two crush on want
to make out with sweated when you were
like re-edited certain things to zoom in
on their cleavage anything degenerate
zoom in on the cleavage slow-mo when
they ever did that
um or were there any that you were like
i really need to double check this
footage over and over and over
there are some when i need to double
check the footage because
i knew that their that their um that
their content in general was a lot
cleaner so i would sometimes i double
checked footage where i was like is this
like gonna like blow back on them in
like some way like stuff like that let's
talk about the real blowing um
specifically whose back did you want to
blow out yeah oh yeah i'm making
platoon's super attractive i think
megafitting is super attractive
yes you heard it here first it's not i
don't think that's a crazy statement to
say
no and she's fun and she's you know good
conversation gotta blow her back out you
know
well that one's on the internet so [ __ ]
hey megan what's up the title of this
video
ryan wants to do bacon but hey let's
make sure it says has to go at the end
so
if it comes out you know because he's in
a relationship too you'll hear my anime
wants to blow out man
ryan's
you're both in a relationship so both of
your girls are gonna be like what what
they're both gonna have this like
reaction with the [ __ ] heads
any more cold questions because we're at
the 12th
12th minute and the 22nd segment
unrelated to jk going but going back off
of uh what we spoke about earlier right
i'm really curious about
how we always joke about ryan being
white because of his upbringing
right is is asia i mean you're asian
typically but then i mean
i mean uh um but i would even argue
against that
but
at first glance we look at you you're
asian
but then it's kind of like you said
typically you know typically
asians they they can speak the the home
or whatever yeah you could speak
their new immigrant restaurant talk yeah
yeah yeah they whatever but in your case
like what your grandparents don't really
speak japanese right or your parents
don't my grandparents do or my
grandparents did depending on like the
the side but um they didn't really pass
that down to their kids as much like
especially my dad's side of the family
they were very or he he was like super
bad america he loved america so he was
like he wanted my dad to be like oh yeah
i want you to like assimilate and like
obviously have all these opportunities
that i didn't maybe didn't have as much
or fit in with you know did you did you
have a who in my moment is what i'm
getting
am i japanese identity crisis yeah i
think that's a good question i think a
lot of that was in high school in high
school and like middle school trying to
figure out like
stuff that i knew was my heritage and or
my my culture and stuff like that but i
didn't really like i eventually got to
the point where i'm like oh like no
matter what i don't really care
necessarily like i don't really have any
connection to that poor to that like
side of my on my life and stuff and i
don't think that i feel like a lot of my
friends and stuff who are like third
generation or second generation even
have a big like identity crisis in that
moment where they're trying to reconnect
with their roots and stuff and i
definitely think that that's important
and i think that they should go search
for
whatever they're looking through in that
but for me personally i just kind of i'm
like
who i am is i'm pretty happy with who i
am so all these components whether they
be very japanese or not i feel like
don't really matter that much one day
the dna is going to activate oh yeah
you're gonna you're gonna be like
chilling and one day you're gonna be
like
i need to sniff a dirty underwear oh
that's that's a genius i'm just gonna
get hella perverted uh out of nowhere
your genitalia is going to get blurry
the coming of
of the japanese dna it's maturing you
dude like it's like you're [ __ ]
turning into charizard right now dude
like you know what's funny i think
i think that i am very japanese and like
a lot of my anxieties and stuff i think
that like the things that i stress about
and like
worrying about certain things i think is
very like japanese in the way that my
parents instilled that like work ethic
and held a knife to your stomach or not
i've thought about it a couple times
oh my goodness
when he's cleaning up vomit
midway through i just pulled out my my
ritual knife it was like i could just
[ __ ] do it
also all japanese you are born with a
separate knife yeah and then he was like
it's going to create more of a mess that
this is a pocky knife
you gotta stay strapped bro she's like
i'm gonna be considerate not kill myself
who's gonna clean up my mess
well then i'm stuck with the then i'm
stuck with the guilt of leaving it for
somebody else i'm like i can't be
inconsiderate for somebody else just be
a guilt ghost you've got to clean up
after himself yeah i'd like disembowel
myself and then like scoop it back
what would be your ideal date with megan
[Laughter]
just gotta i'm gonna just totally regret
this portion of my life he's never gonna
come back bro i'll never come back here
ever again the date starts out
at uh we build a desk together yeah dude
together yeah help her with like the
renovations she likes building i know
nothing about it it's a 12-hour date it
goes from noon to midnight it just
sounds like
you're like living together that's six
hours bro you don't go on twitter six
hours no twelve to twelve no never mind
four hour days bro well yeah what's your
ideal date what's what what's your
drunk bro are you guys dancing building
she's building he's cleaning [ __ ] for
12 hours
every time i get closer to giving an
answer you're just like and then derail
just [ __ ]
never answer this question i put it all
back in
those are like my guts right now it's
just being pulled no you give your
answer an ideal date just [ __ ] it for
12 hours i gave them options i don't
know
because you seem stumped you know what i
mean you were hooking them up
honestly so out of those three what
would you pick i'm very i'm very i'm
very go with the flow kind of guys so if
it's like a matter of like coffee date
or something like that that's totally
fine with me lots of conversation stuff
like that yeah it's so boring i'm boring
classy dude thanks
you won't do hugh hefner style put
trampolines everywhere after
just
a lot of anxiety bro
you want to go to jump zone for a good
day
no that's nothing says like first date
like [ __ ] like
trampoline volleyball or not volleyball
[ __ ] what's that uh dodge ball cause
somebody have that jump sound or
whatever yeah let's go [ __ ] it's a cute
[ __ ] well you should go there before you
eat
well she's gonna be puking and then he's
gonna throw him
up you gotta clean it up oh man he
watches like [ __ ] it's not as funny as
it looks man
wait i recorded this too
i don't want to see megan throw it up
i'm like ryan what'd you make megan
throw up yeah why'd you do that right
[Laughter]
why did you do these things
[ __ ] throwing up your ideal date you're
weird dude
what are you japanese or something [ __ ]
that's your blurred dick
[ __ ] fetish
where'd you get those panties
the vending machine that's a pretty
that's a pretty hot seat that was a hot
seat thanks for playing a lot hey thanks
bro we appreciate you ruining my search
history
god that means you're a g dude
anybody that [ __ ] searches this is
just going to be like give it up for me
thank you what's up
[ __ ] trampoline like shoes
future employers are going to like
search my name they just be like wow
this video has a million views or
they're gonna be like this guy's a
straight shooter we're going to hire you
either going very good or dad likes to
play ball dude that's awesome bro
he's a team player if i ever had to
watch like a government agency or
something like that
because i've heard of like crazy
interviews for like people that have
needed security clearances and stuff and
they're just going to be like so um
trampoline
be like look man it was a different time
in my life
[Laughter]
sir
buy a knife real quick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you